[Music]
nope
this is not a video about urban camping
it's about 5g testing and yes why the
best 5g experience you can get right now
is on the streets of the biggest US
cities in a camping tent with a fan and
a cooler I'm dead serious about the
cooler it's all gonna make sense soon I
promise
but first some 5g basics 5g is the
network that comes after 4G or LTE and
it's gonna be so fast it's gonna knock
your socks off
people are crazy hyped about 5g and all
of the innovation it's supposed to bring
all four of the US carriers Verizon AT&T
Sprint and t-mobile have just started
rolling out 5g in pockets of the u.s. to
get real 5g you need a new phone
the $1,300 Samsung Galaxy S 10 5 G is
one of the first and it's available on
all the carriers so over the last few
weeks I packed up my gear and embarked
on a 5g testing tour I hit up four US
cities to test all four of the US
carriers 5g networks with Samsung's new
phones that's what I'm doing here in
Chicago
testing Sprint and Verizon network turns
out 5g is freaking fast when you're
outdoors and you're standing in the
right spot and it's not too hot out and
the stars are aligned just right
[Music]
right here in Chicago I'm getting crazy
fast speeds on Verizon's 5g network and
got even higher speeds in Denver last
week on speed test I've been getting
around 900 megabits per second that's
about 25 times as fast as the average
LTE download and that's at least nine
times faster than my home Wi-Fi in
Denver I got even faster speeds in some
spots
I hit 1,800 megabits per second it was
nuts I've been able to download a 10
gigabyte file in 2 minutes and 40
seconds the whole latest season of
stranger things or 2.1 gigabytes 34
seconds on LTE that can take an hour a
2.5 gigabytes 50 seconds right now in
the US no matter where you are or what
network you're on only downloads use 5g
so if you upload a video or a file
you'll get 4G speeds once the networks
of all those uploads will get faster -
here in New York City on t-mobile's
network I've been getting closer to 300
to 400 megabits per second not as fast
as Verizon in Chicago in Denver or AT&T
which I tested in Atlanta but still fast
enough to download that 10 gigabyte file
in just under 5 minutes in my tests AT&T
and Verizon tied for the fastest speeds
I wish I could tell you those speeds are
everywhere and the coverage is wonderful
and the world has changed
forever but no here in Chicago it's
crazy fast because there's a Verizon 5g
node or cell right there see that that's
what's broadcasting the signal but when
I moved my tent up the block say 400 to
600 feet I get no 5g signal only 4G same
thing happens with t-mobile's network in
Manhattan's Lower East Side and when I
go indoors I drop right back to 4G this
is because of the types of 5g being
implemented right now
[Music]
the type currently being used by Verizon
AT&T Mobile is called millimeter waves
it's very fast but only covers shorter
distances and doesn't penetrate walls
concrete or other obstacles the other
type is called mid band 5g and it's
being used by Sprint which just launched
its 5g service here in Chicago it's not
as fast but it has much wider coverage
and better signal penetration in this
spot I'm getting around 300 megabits per
second on Sprint's Network I can take my
tent anywhere in the city and get
coverage I can even go inside my hotel
lobby and while the speeds are not
blistering it's still pretty decent I
downloaded the latest season of stranger
things in three minutes and 20 seconds
yeah it seems pretty crazy that right
now you have to be outdoors or in a
camping tent to get 5g signal on at
least three of the networks as the
carriers or the network's add more
spectrum it should improve this brings
me to the biggest problem of them all
the heat throughout my testing the
Verizon AT&T and t-mobile Galaxy 5g
phones would get very warm due to the
hot Summer Sun and sometimes one or two
download tests and the phone would just
turn off 5g and go back to 4G yep
bye-bye signal this didn't happen with
the Sprint version at times I registered
the phone getting over a hundred degrees
with this laser thermometer the tent
provided much-needed shade and a fan or
air conditioning actually seems to cool
down the back but a few minutes in the
cooler helps the most
in fact engineers testing these phones
have told me they use ice as well
another solution just use 5g at night
a Samsung spokeswoman says this thermal
management is done by design to minimize
energy usage and optimize battery
performance as 5g technology and the
ecosystem evolve it's only going to get
better she added we're clearly at the
starting line of this so-called 5g race
it's very early days and very not ready
for you but even just the first taste of
the speeds make me excited about what's
to come
blazing fast connections even when
you're not roughing it in the wild
[Music]